que vous étiez fumeur avant dans pour
lancer ça ouais de gros fumeur de gros
fumeurs des méchants fumeurs un paquet
par jour pour moi et moi 3 3
fumer énormément et je t'ai vraiment le
pire cap possible de fumeur que tu peux
imaginer quoi et là vous avez arrêté
complètement depuis 10 ans
et donc vapoter pour vous ça vous a
vraiment aidé à arrêter de fumer ça a
été l'épiphanie même et pour ça l'est
pour de nombreux fumeurs d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que c'est si efficace
parce que ça reproduit exactement le le
geste de fumée on a on exale quelque
chose on a le parfum en plus et en plus
le côté un petit peu geek ça peut avoir
des fois sur le sur la sur la vape qui
m'a beaucoup plu au début et c'est ça
qui fait que c'est si efficace on
reproduit exactement les mêmes choses
toute la journée on les voit
je crois que moi je suis au paddle avec
lui toujours que c'est vrai
[Rires]
est-ce qu'il y a des dangers quand même
à papoter Bruno alors juste pour
clarifier effectivement dangereux dans
le tabac donc dans la cigarette ce sont
les hydrocarbures policycliques
c'est-à-dire les goudrons les produits
qui dérivent de la combustion qui sont
oxydants et qui vont induire non
seulement des risques cardiovasculaires
des risques respiratoires mais aussi un
risque cancérigène comme vous le savez
beaucoup de cancers qui sont liés à la
consommation de tabac le problème le
problème du tabac c'est qu'il y a en
plus une substance psychoactive qui est
la nicotine qui va faire qu'on va
dépendre du tabac et donc on va
poursuivre la consommation alors même
que l'on connaît ces dangers pour la
santé ce que vient d'expliquer Bruno
j'ai tout compris ça y est c'est qu'en
fait les produits qui sont dangereux
c'est pas nicotine mais la nicotine ça
va te faire revenir parce que c'est
addict
donc eux il y a pas les produits
dangereux voilà alors maintenant
effectivement
la cigarette électronique elle ne
contient a priori comme produit actif
que la nicotine et donc effectivement
elle est censée permettre à quelqu'un
qui a déjà fumé qui est dépendant de la
nicotine d'arrêter la cigarette pour
éviter les risques liés les risques
cardiovasculaires liés au tabac d'accord
je dirais là où il y a évidemment une
discussion et un débat c'est de mettre à
disposition la cigarette électronique et
d'autres types de dérivés on appelle ça
les puffs pour les jeunes qui n'ont
jamais pris de tabac comme moyen
d'entrer et à ce moment-là effectivement
le risque puisque c'est ces produits
contiennent la substance psychoactée
peut-être même ne contient pas la
nicotine ensuite on évolue vers la
cigarette électronique qui contient la
nicotine c'est le seul danger en fait
alors donc ce qu'on est pour résumer
parce que je résumeur ici moi en fait
c'est pas eux mais pour les ados tout ça
ça peut comment jamais filmé pour pour
fumer derrière voilà alors moi je te dis
Bruno après après moi de ce que je vois
ce que c'est vrai que
je suis très contente pas mal d'ados on
joue à la plaie et tout ça
non c'est vrai tu vois et c'est vrai que
en fait c'est où ils vont moi je pense
direct vers la cigarette où il reste sur
la poche vraiment c'est voilà c'est
c'est pas de question à 14-15 ans et
s'ils doivent fumer il fume ils vont pas
se dire je vais d'abord faire la pub et
après généralement il reste sur la pop
ou bien ici ceux qui fument voilà il
vous avez raison c'est pour quand le
rôle des autorités de santé et les
autorités politiques c'est justement de
limiter l'accès de limiter la publicité
normalement ce sont ces des produits qui
ne doivent être accessibles qu'au-delà
de 18 ans et la publicité de ces
produits est strictement interdit pour
les parents qui nous regardent qui ont
des qui ont des ados
en vrai il faut mieux leur dire parce
que on sait très bien les parents quand
ils vont dire à leurs enfants arrête de
fumer ils vont se cacher pour aller
fumer et puis on va les créer ils vont
les cramer un moment
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux leur dire vas-y
on ne l'a pas voilà vapote ou ou bien
voilà il vaut mieux leur dire vapote au
moins non je crois qu'il faut il faut
jamais culpabiliser un adolescent par
contre il faut lui expliquer
tranquillement et sereinement quels sont
les risques de tel ou tel substance et
là effectivement tout le monde a bien
compris aujourd'hui le danger des
drogues et donc dans les puffs dans la
cigarette électronique il y a un produit
psychoactif qui est la nicotine qui va
donc donner une accoutumance aux
produits et donc une dépendance et donc
la personne va continuer peut ensuite
effectivement et c'est ça le paradoxe
passer de de la cigarette électronique
vers le tabac et donc c'est
inutile oui bien sûr alors oui tout à
fait mais effectivement il y a une étape
intermédiaire et c'est là où il y a une
certaine un certain vis c'est qu'en fait
on va rendre l'adolescent habitué au
gestes et à l'inhalation
probablement d'un produit très agréable
avec des arômes et effectivement sans
qu'il fasse attention le vendeur va lui
vendre peut-être un produit qui contient
de la nicotine et il va en devenir
dépendant etc oui
pas de combustion ce qu'on ce qu'on
aspire c'est qu'il y a pas tout à fait
alors c'est pas actif tout à fait donc
[Rires]
tout ce qui est arôme ça n'a aucune
conséquence parce que de respirer ces
arômes chimiques toute la journée ça
doit quand même avoir dans les poumons
ça doit pas être formidable alors vous
avez raison on va dire le poumon est
quelque chose qui a de sorte très
facilement tout type de substance bien
mieux que le tube digestif et donc on va
dire théoriquement dans des études
expérimentales ce type de produit a été
démontré comme non cancérigène
maintenant on ne connaît pas au long
cours leurs effets ça se retrouve pas
dans le foie tout à fait ce sont des
substances exogènes on appelle ça des
xénobiotiques qui peuvent donner des
métabolites dans le foie et qui peuvent
avoir des conséquences donc on peut pas
écarter des conséquences sur long court
malgré tout à nouveau ce type de produit
n'a pas les dangers du tabac Florent
Florent et David est-ce qu'il y a des
saveurs qui peuvent être moins voilà
moins gênantes que d'autres alors en
fait moi j'aimerais commencer par dire
que c'est très bienveillant tout ça mais
on déclare en fait tous les Français
alors en France on a la chance d'avoir
une filière assez exemplaire sur pour la
vape les fabricants doivent déclarer 6
mois avant de mettre sur le marché à
lancest qui est l'agence nationale qui
contrôle aussi les médicaments et qui
vérifient la liste des comptes de ce que
tous les e-liquides contiennent donc on
a cette grande chance en France d'avoir
un organisme qui va de toute façon ce
nez rouge s'il y a notamment un CMR donc
un principe cancérigène dans les arômes
donc les arômes sont quand même passé au
crible avant d'être mis sur le marché
d'accord quand même une c'est important
de le dire aussi Delphine oui
effectivement je pense que la bonsoir je
pense que la cigarette électronique
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
cigarette électronique permet autant
d'arrêter que de commencer parce
qu'effectivement pour mon expérience moi
j'ai jamais fumé et dernièrement un
copain m'a prêté ça à cigarette
électronique et franchement
ça a donné envie effectivement le goût
mais rien que le rien que la volute je
trouvais ça très bien et donc je pense
que si l'état encore une fois et en
partenariat s'il était un partenariat
avec le milieu médical était vraiment
intelligent et voulait le bien des
Français je pense que la cigarette
électronique devrait être prescrite
uniquement pour des gens disposition
pour des gens qui veulent arrêter la
cigarette mais elles devraient pas être
open comme ça pour divertir dans les
magasins
essentiellement réservé aux personnes
pour le sevrage tabagique et je crois
qu'effectivement même une personne qui
veut sevrer du tabac doit consulter un
tabacologue parce qu'il y a plusieurs
modalités de devoirs
l'accompagner l'accompagner
non mais c'est vrai c'est lui
mais c'était quelqu'un d'autre
[Rires]
elle n'est pas faite pour tout le monde
c'est pourquoi il faut passer par la vie
et c'est pour ça qu'elle est interdite
au mineur on on va le rappeler parce que
la polémique la vape et les mineurs
c'est une fausse polémique aujourd'hui
les gouvernements le gouvernement
le gouvernement doit faire en sorte que
les mineurs Cyril n'est pas accès à ses
produits comme l'alcool comme le tabac
comme la vape c'est le même paradigme il
faut arrêter il faut sortir les jeunes
de ça alors les laisser rentrer Bruno
est-ce que c'est vrai que dans le
liquide pour recharger il y a la
présence de métaux lourds qui pourraient
impacter la santé comme du nickel
extrêmement faible normalement ça n'a
pas de conséquences pour la santé il
faut savoir que les produits qui se
trouvent dans dans le le liquide et bien
sont en quantité plus importante rendu
compte que dans l'atmosphère et donc
effectivement on ne peut pas écarter des
conséquences à très long terme mais en
toxicité aiguë la quantité de métaux
présents négligeable et non toxique oui
on voit plein de campagnes publiques
pour arrêter le tabac on parle des
patchs on parle des gommes et on parle
jamais de la cigarette électronique il
le propose pas le gouvernement pourquoi
si c'est une bonne alternative
c'est une bonne question
si on fait une connerie je pense que
voilà
renverser en vérité parce qu'on a 205
français par jour qui meurent du tabac
205 c'est colossal et le principe de
précaution faudrait le retourner en
disant on a une solution efficace et les
études le prouvent on a 15 ans d'études
derrière nous qui prouvent ça que c'est
beaucoup plus efficace que tout les
patchs et les gommes et toutes les
choses qu'on a pu inventer jusque là
pour arrêter de fumer
et c'est tout bonne question
sachant que les ministres
il y a pas encore de mort sur la
cigarette électronique pour tous ceux
qui ont fait des cours SVT on a quand
même les poumons les bronches et ensuite
les bronchioles c'est quand même quelque
chose de très très fin et normalement à
part de l'air il n'y a rien qui doit
rentrer dans les poumons en fait donc
même ça un jour on s'en rendra compte
que c'est
ancrasser les bronchioles et puis
ensuite enfin ça fait que le poumon
on compare la vape toujours avec le
tabac il faut toujours remettre ça
moyen de sevrage si vous pouvez ne rien
prendre
ne rien prendre alors si vous fumez et
que vous voulez arrêter ça peut l'être
un des moyens mais attention je ne suis
pas certain que ça soit le meilleur et
je ne suis pas certain qu'un sur le
tabacologue va vous loyers
est-ce qu'il faut être riche pour
papoter ça coûte combien par rapport à
un paquet de cigarettes ça vous
intéresse pas ma question
j'étais en train de me convertir
excuse-moi pardon je suis désolé on
s'est tous vu en cours
combien ça coûte absolument pas et c'est
la première raison de pour quelqu'un qui
arrête
deux arguments c'est que alors la
réponse est non c'est bien bien moins
cher pour un fumeur de vapoter et c'est
la première raison d'aller vers l'AVAP
aujourd'hui ce qui est dramatique c'est
pas la santé malheureusement parce que
ça c'est quand le médecin dit il faut
arrêter que les gens vont vers la vape
mais c'est le budget et donc je reprends
le deuxième argument qui était de dire
il faudrait donner ça que via
tabacologue ce serait un grand problème
parce que ce serait freiner l'accès aux
fumeurs de ce produit qui a pas envie de
rentrer dans une démarche médicale mais
qui rentre dans une démarche d'économie
donc si on lui ferme la porte des
boutiques en disant il faut d'abord
passer par la case médecin on divise par
10 la motivation des fumeurs aller vers
ça et comme David l'a dit nous on se bat
pour que les fumeurs et la bonne
information vers ça et notamment je suis
vapoteur
donc pour avoir de jolis cheveux comme
David soyez vos Potter si vous êtes
[Applaudissements]
merci à vous deux